[Musique]
il me faut des moutons deux moutons
pour faire un barbecue à mon peloton
[Musique]
les deux moutons c'était les civils que
nous allions assassiner
[Musique]
entre 2002 et 2008 des milliers de
colombiens ont été assassinés par
l'armée puis présenté comme des
guerriers roses tués au combat on les
appelle les faux positifs dans le jargon
militaire
[Musique]
pour représenter les 6402 faux positifs
les malnés
mon fils et mon neveu sont sortis une
après-midi faire un tour et manger une
glace ils ne sont jamais revenus
ils ont été déguisés en Guerriero ces
criblés de balles dans un quartier du
sud de Bogota
et parmi ces maires de victimes
réclamant justice la plupart de ces
crimes sont restés impunis
[Musique]
sur la fiche les visages d'une douzaine
de généraux dans les années 2000 leur
bataillons ont commis le plus grand
nombre de faux positifs pour faire
gonfler les statistiques de guerriers au
sabattus
ils sont très déjà ils ont encore
augmenté
très saletés de généraux
[Musique]
c'est qu'ils disent la vérité au pays
qui sont les responsables de ce massacre
les généraux les ministres de la Défense
Alvaro ou ribé le président de l'époque
[Musique]
quelques heures plus tard en pleine nuit
ces visages seront effacés
qui ont fait ça ils sont juste à côté
ils sont venus de nuit entre 22h et 4
heures du matin
non reconnue par l'armée colombienne le
scandale des faux positifs est encore
tabou
au début des années 2000 la Colombie est
à feu et à sang la guérilla des phares
contrôle une partie du territoire leurs
ennemis les paramilitaires s'aiment la
terreur avec souvent la complicité de
l'armée
en 2002 Alvaro urbé était élu président
il a promis d'écraser les guerriers
héros
il met en œuvre sa politique sécuritaire
les années suivantes sont celles d'une
vaste offensive militaire
les résultats s'affichent en nombre de
guerriers héros tués
en 2008 le scandale éclate
[Musique]
les crimes sont attribués à quelques
brebis galeuses
le prestige des forces armées
colombiennes dans le cœur du peuple et
aux yeux de la communauté internationale
ne peut être ternie par les délits
commis en raison des fautes
administratives de certains de ses
membres
les premières victimes à être
découvertes venaient de sohatcha une
banlieue pauvre du sud de Bogota
[Musique]
jaune bleu et rouge les couleurs de la
Colombie
notre Colombie qui a commis tant de
massacre
Oscar et sans emploi il part vendre des
vêtements dans la ville commerciale de
kukuta à la frontière avec le Venezuela
il a disparu le 31 décembre 2007
il était 23h quand il nous a téléphoné
pour la dernière fois
nous n'avons plus aucune nouvelle de lui
la famille signale sa disparition sa
trace sera retrouvée en 2011
je suis arrivée à la police judiciaire
et une femme m'a dit Madame nous l'avons
trouvé
être fils est dans une fausse commune il
est mort dans un affrontement avec
l'armée
rien de tout ça
depuis la famille se bat pour récupérer
son corps les militaires l'auraient jeté
dans une fausse commune non encore
localisée à 500 km du lieu de
disparition
cela détruit une famille
c'était tous des jeunes des jeunes qui
aidaient leurs familles
ils engine des innocents
d'affronter des gens qui leur
répondaient avec des armes
ce sont des lâches
mon fils était une personne incroyable
un garçon très honnête nous lui avons
enseigné de très bonnes valeurs
[Musique]
regardez c'est lui
peu à peu la Colombie des couvre que la
macabre pratique touchait tout le
territoire les faux positifs se comptent
par centaines puis par milliers devant
la justice colombienne les procès
s'éternisent ou sont classés sans suite
seule une infime partie des coupables
sont emprisonnés de simples soldats ou
des sous-officiers
10 ans plus tard la justice spéciale
pour la paix la jette se saisit du
dossier
ce tribunal de justice restaurative
opère dans cet édifice moderne du nord
de Bogota
né de l'accord de paix avec la guérilla
des Farcs il est chargé de juger les
crimes de tous les acteurs du conflit
[Musique]
et cela
c'est une nouvelle vision de la justice
la mission de la
la mission de la giep et de stabiliser
la paix en Colombie
et l'un des pires crimes commis dans le
cadre du conflit armé interne sont les
exécutions extrajudiciaires
les premières enquêtes approfondie de la
giep nous indique qu'il s'agissait d'une
politique systématique politique
systématique non ce n'était pas
simplement le fait de brebis galeuse
sinon on a organisa c'était une action
organisée par des appareils de pouvoir
incrustés dans les forces militaires
la justice pour la paix reprend les
archives de la justice ordinaire et même
ses propres enquêtes grâce aux
témoignages des victimes comme des
accusés dans ce système de justice
restaurative ceux qui disent la vérité
ne feront pas de prison mais des travaux
d'intérêt général et des actes de
réparation aux victimes
début 2021 la justice spéciale donne ses
premiers résultats pour le cas 003 celui
des exécutions de civils par des agents
de l'État elle annonce un nombre inédit
de victimes trois fois plus que le
recensement antérieur
parmi elles le fils de Doris
je m'appelle Maria Doris Terrada mère
d'Oscar Alexander morales Terrada
je suis une des mamans de mafapo les
mères des faux positifs
mon fils en ce moment est toujours dans
une fosse commune
je me bats depuis 13 ans pour le
retrouver
et je vais y arriver merci
[Musique]
devant les locaux de la justice spéciale
pour la paix
pour soutenir leur travail et les
encourager après l'annonce du
recensement de 602 cas
[Musique]
c'est le montage qu'ils ont fait contre
mon frère
a demandé aux autres qui voulait tirer
personne n'a voulu alors c'est lui qui
l'a tué
il lui ont mis des armes puis des bottes
ils lui ont mis deux bottes gauche
puis encore des armes
[Musique]
et ils me l'ont habillé en gris
dans les audiences de la JP on parle de
la responsabilité des officiers
mais quand les commandants viennent
déclarer ils disent qu'ils ne savaient
rien des faux positifs
il rejette toute la faute sur les moins
gradés
pendant la pandémie de covid-19 les
audiences de la justice pour la paix se
tiennent de manière virtuelle
[Musique]
en visioconférence les proches des
victimes disent leur témoignages face au
magistrats
pour les familles la justice pour la
paix et naître l'espoir de voir enfin
tous les coupables punis après des
années de paralysie dans les tribunaux
Sébastien boraka appartient à un
collectif d'avocats de victimes de
crimes d'État il représente la famille
de Doris
j'ai ici entre les mains deux des 12
dossiers que le bureau du procureur
général détient dans l'enquête de la
justice ordinaire sur le meurtre d'Oscar
Alexander moral esterrada par l'armée de
terre colombienne ici nous n'avons que
ceux qui ont commis l'acte criminel qui
manque-t-il ceux qui ont donné une
partie de l'ordre
les accusés sont 7 soldats et deux
sous-officiers selon eux
oscar a été tué avec deux autres jeunes
hommes lors d'une opération militaire
contre un groupe armé
si l'on reprend le dossier et que l'on
analyse leur témoignage on constate de
sérieux contradictions entre eux
le procès n'a jamais abouti malgré les
preuves contre l'armée
d'après l'inspection du corps d'Oscar
Alexander moral esterrada il portait un
fusil à K47 avec un chargeur
une recherche de traces de poudre a été
réalisée sur ses mains pour établir s'il
avait effectivement tiré avec ce fusil
et il a été démontré qu'il n'avait pas
tiré
les chefs locaux des renseignements
militaires ont ensuite confessé pas
seulement pour Oscar mais aussi pour 33
autres victimes que toutes ces
opérations étaient fausses
basé ou pas dans le nord de la Colombie
le bataillon la Popa et l'une des
garnisons les plus meurtrières
spéciales
quelques gouttes
et je me sens mal mais j'en prendrai
sous la langue
dans un hôtel de veille du part Doris se
prépare à retourner sur les lieux du
crime de son fils Oscar mort en 2008
sous les balles du bataillon la pop
sa famille ainsi que d'autres proches de
victimes des défenseurs des droits de
l'homme et son avocat l'accompagne
Oscar et les deux autres jeunes tués
avec lui ont été transportés de coucouta
à El kope à plus de 500 km
d'après l'enquête des avocats ils sont
tombés dans le piège mortel de l'armée
en acceptant une fausse promesse
d'emploi probablement un travail comme
journalier dans une ferme
à El kopey Doris découvre que l'endroit
où son fils est enseveli et recouvert
d'une construction qui rendra plus
difficile les recherches
regarde des familles de disparus
viennent te rencontrer
la municipalité bâtie ici un cimetière
dans les années 2000 des dizaines de
victimes anonymes du conflit ont été
enterrés par l'armée quelque part sur ce
vaste terrain beaucoup étaient des faux
positifs
la justice pour la paix a ordonné
l'arrêt des travaux en attendant que ce
soit organisé des fouilles
en litres de sang que les captures ne
comptaient pas
tout ce qui leur fallait c'était des
litres de sang
et les familles des victimes ont le
droit de savoir la vérité
lorsqu'on fournissait des résultats
il donnait des permissions
[Musique]
des permissions à des soldats qui
patrouillaient 4 5 7 mois dans la jungle
sans jamais voir leurs proches
cet homme était sous-officier dans le
bataillon la peau pas il a accepté de
témoigner à Bogota sous couvert
d'anonymat
je suis entré dans l'armée en 2005
je me suis engagé par amour pour la
patrie
ma famille n'avait pas les moyens de me
payer des études
suite à une faute disciplinaire il doit
fournir des résultats sous peine d'être
renvoyé
à organiser avec le sergent des
renseignements et le major les morts au
combat que nous allions présenter
le sergent était en contact avec celui
qui nous a mené les personnes trompées
c'était un civil il est mort ensuite
dans d'étranges circonstances à bord
d'un véhicule du bataillon
apparemment les freins ont lâché
le recruteur cherche les victimes en
leur faisant croire qu'il y a une
promesse de travail dans une ferme pour
cueillir du café par exemple
ce recruteur les amènent au point où ces
exécutions vont avoir lieu
dans mon cas il les amène en ville
comment je vais aller chercher
dans un
à qui appartenait ce 4 4
colonel et au major
nous leur disions qu'il n'allait pas
travailler accueillir du café mais
qu'ils avaient été recrutés par les
paramilitaires des autodéfense Unies de
Colombie
et que donc il devait enfiler des
uniformes et ensuite on leur disait
qu'on allait s'entraîner au tir
on place à distance les deux personnes
qui vont être tuées l'une à un point
l'autre à un autre point
couverte par la végétation de la zone et
face à eux des soldats qui savaient ce
que nous allions faire
sous les ordres des commandants
[Musique]
il tire sur l'autre
et voilà
le sous-officier n'aurait pas participé
à l'assassinat du fils de Doris mais la
mise en scène était souvent la même
Oscar morales et ses deux compagnons
d'infortune ont été abattus au bord
d'une route de campagne loin du village
on leur mémoire Doris et ses proches
vont y planter des arbres
c'est à cet endroit qu'ils ont rapporté
le prétendu combat la description était
qu'avant le virage ils ont affronté 10
personnes selon certains soldats vins
selon d'autres soldats et à la fin les
trois jeunes étaient au sol
un serait tombé de ce côté et les deux
autres du côté de la rivière
[Musique]
la dictée masse dans tous les cas
les victimes étaient issues de la
population vulnérable et son ose elle
venait des quartiers pauvres ou bien
c'était le voleur du quartier ou encore
des handicapés mentaux
finalement la cible c'était la
vulnérabilité le manque d'opportunités
le manque d'emploi d'éducation
qui a donné l'ordre
si on organise cela dans un ordre
hiérarchique
alors il faut commencer par cette
politique appelée la sécurité
démocratique
nous étions sous le gouvernement
d'Alvaro Ribet
et l'armée de terre était alors dirigée
par Marion Montoya
tement colonel dans la 15e division de
l'armée responsable des opérations il
validait les faux rapports lors des
exécutions de civils commises par son
unité il a avoué sa culpabilité devant
la justice pour la paix
j'ai rencontré le général Montoya quand
il était à la tête du commando conjoint
de la région Caraïbes
la première fois qu'il m'a affronté il
m'a dit vous aussi devez me fournir des
résultats
sur un ton de plaisanterie il m'a dit
trouver des morts mettez-leur un
uniforme et présentez-les je n'y ai pas
prêté attention sur le moment mais cela
m'a surpris pourquoi faisait-il de
telles insinuations
[Musique]
le général Mario Montoya est le plus
haut gradé à comparaître devant la
justice pour la paix il nie toute
responsabilité dans ce massacre de civil
mais de nombreux témoignages mettent en
cause ces méthodes Mario Montoya était
l'un des piliers de la politique
sécurité du président Alvaro Ribe de
2006 à 2008 il assume le commandement de
l'armée de terre
il est passé devant chacun des officiers
leur a demandé combien de morts au
combat et il nous a donné un délai une
audioplasme si en moins d'un mois nous
ne commencions pas à produire des
résultats et nous relevait de nos
fonctions le résultat
de nombreux commandants ne voulaient pas
y prendre part et on préfère partir
c'est une chance pour eux qu'ils soient
partis
malheureusement nous qui sommes restés
avons commencé à jouer un rôle
qui a été la plus grande des honte pour
ce pays
il existe aujourd'hui une sorte de pacte
du silence dans l'armée colombienne les
ex militaires témoignant devant la
justice le font souvent aux péril de
leur vie le colonel rincoln a fait
l'objet d'une tentative d'assassinat il
s'est vu attribuer une voiture blindée
et des gardes du corps
lors de cession publique de la justice
pour la paix de plus en plus d'ex
membres de l'armée reconnaissent leur
crime face aux victimes
en 4 ans plus de 600 militaires ont été
entendus quelques généros et colonels
commencent à appeler des coupables
dévoilant toujours plus l'ampleur du
scandale
[Musique]
oscarparat est l'un des trois magistrats
de la justice pour la paix chargée de la
faire
[Musique]
ce que nous avons fait c'est exploiter
les outils que la justice
transitionnelle nous donne pour
promouvoir une clarification profonde de
la vérité mais aussi des scénarios de
dialogues réparateurs
nous a permis de contribuer à rompre
avec le négationnisme qui a caractérisé
pendant de nombreuses années la réponse
institutionnelle de l'État à ce
phénomène
stathal pourquoi poco s'avancer nous
mettons en lumière l'évidence de la
généralité du phénomène
la systématicité des faits et un large
éventail de responsabilité
que nous allons progressivement
clarifier
l'instruction durera encore plusieurs
années puis un tribunal pour la paix
prononcera les 100 ans ce qui manque à
la vérité risque jusqu'à 20 ans de
prison ferme
la justice spéciale n'est pas habilité à
juger un ex-président Alvaro Ribe et son
ministre de la Défense Juan Manuel
Santos ne sont pour leur pas inquiétés
les mères continuent de demander qui a
donné l'ordre
elle poursuivent leur lutte ponctuée de
rituels pour faire ce deuil impossible
[Musique]
nous allons la voir
pour continuer à avancer sur ce chemin
qui est bien long
bien difficile
à l'unité de recherche des personnes
disparues à localiser des fosses
communes et commencer les fouilles sur
le terrain vague où serait enterré le
fils de Doris une quarantaine de corps
ont été trouvés mais leur identification
pourrait prendre des années
l'affaire des faux positifs n'est que
l'un des Noirs épisodes de
l'interminable conflit colombien au
total il a fait depuis 1985 450
000 morts et plus de 120 000 disparus
[Musique]